nella puntata precedente asta che mi
faccia voto sta cosa che non si sa mai
ok 1 le belle a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo lo video sono parigi
oggi sono tanti sub i biglietti erano
rimasti che avevo se vi ricordate fatto
la roba della statua che questa qua a
destra
non so dove sia per tutto scompartimento
però so di per certo che la tipa sta qua
quindi corri ok io non ho idea di dove
si sia aperto il suo scompartimento qui
però se la tipa non se ne va è un
problema
la parola greco sta scritta sulla porta
quindi usiamo una chiave greco led che
vediamo che c'è è permesso beh è la
sostanza ma ricordavo a ci sono tre
uccelli e un uomo lo vedi l'uomo highly
ok mi sono emozionato per figure non si
possono muovere perché sono ancorate va
bene quindi devo trovare altre figure
infilarle lì sicuramente c'è un triciclo
c'è una bambola nel letto ma c'è
qualcosa che luccica ho trovato una
manovella non ho idea di che cosa che
cosa possa servirmi questa si apre tra
l'altro anche se aperto la porta per qua
va bene gesù che caga vedo gente che
vasti sopra che è successo
la porta greco vabbè apriamola c'è gente
che va di sopra è bruttissimo st parte
di gioco o finalmente sono entrati nella
stanza nuovo vediamo cosa c'è qua dentro
dei vestiti delle bambole cose messe a
caso bello sta porta posto povero è una
roba di manià netto che puoi prenderle a
posso spingerle devo tirare questi
affari quindi è però non solo non ho
idea di quale sia la convince e non mi
so esprimere però avete capito non ho
idea di quale sia il d'ordine però vabbè
andiamo avanti lo stesso comunque
ragazzi a parte tutto sto casino mi
ricordo che fuori sono andato più avanti
c'era questa cosa che volevo fare da un
pezzo c'era un filo parte qua c'è un
giardino che bo come fai a entrarci non
lo so però c'era un filo qua
l'ultima volta avevo visto eccolo questo
che può essere tagliato e dato è un filo
metallico come
penso sia all i do fuoco oppure cioè le
pinze tagliarle rob e per questo avvio
ho trovato un ramo grandissimo come fano
taglio l'hotel lucera la segheria
ritaglio la segreteria
mamma mia pizzeria qua aver spostato
tutto ma ho ancora mai capito che so
eccola qua pizzeria meglio se riesco a
tagliarla a tagliarla il problema è che
non so neanche come farla partire
stamattina attivati la manovella ma
vaffan cuore io penso fosse per un
triciclo sta roba qua barais casa tutto
vai zio vai spacca lo c'era una chiave
dentro ospedali non ho capito c'è una
c'era del sangue qua dentro
questo è vero sangue quali orrori si
insidiano all'interno di questo doloroso
ho trovato la chiave croce molto bene
non so cosa mi serva ma vabbè andiamo
via non si può salvare salviamo non si
può salvare scappando via
ho trovato una chiave croce molto bene
la chiave croce puoi aprire quante
miliardi di così posso aprire lo stadio
non lo so porco demonio che caga
incredibile
ce l'avevo di fianco ecco la prima roba
che diverrebbero controllare questa gara
che non se non si apre un problema
perché la tipa mi sta inseguendo
e infatti non è questo la tipa ha smesso
di seguirmi grazie a dio che la croce
ecco la croce la chiave a croce apriva
cimitero ciò i corvi è solo e ricordi
quelli che hanno visto prima le cose
sono che erano posizionati come che
erano quelli che stavano fermi ancorati
l'uomo sta qua una tomba era qua
all'uomo cosa devo vaio era quale ho
visto io me lo ricordo da toccare i
corvi a devo spostare i corvi nella
direzione della fai pensare a questa era
giusto ma è come disposto aspetta ma se
si spostano a caso lo sapevo fare io no
scusami eh non mi ricordo come era
combinazione ti pare fosse tipo
allora vi dovrete muovere come vi dico
io come vi dico uno stalin 1 st lee
bravo e l'altro sta qua a sinistra a
sinistra ancora bis 1 noli giù o no non
è lì in quella di mezzo quella di me no
quella di mezzo di porco schiphol aido
quella di mezzo quella di mezzo quella
di mezzo non ci credo ho mai visto si è
aperto uno slot trovato la libeccio chi
mio dio fu tutti i corvi data amo
riguarda beccatevi a vicenda sei anni
per st chiave minghi impossibile ci ha
messo una vita non si muoverà mai nel
modo giusto
torniamo dentro c'è libeccio di patente
libeccio chi mi seguite su youtube e
andavo di sopra questa chiave pieghe
piagne che succede adesso può ha pure va
in giro con mano ad avvicinare quella va
in giro col coltello felice perché non
sei felice perché sono trattate in
questo modo cosa ho fatto mi hai
ammazzato due volte accoltellando mi in
faccia ti basta o vado avanti
li sento tutti quanti che parlano in
città
pover uomo e la sua donna che board e
non solo lire lei è pazza e pazza e
senza figli ed è una disgrazia non mi
ami più vero io non ti amo più
dimmelo spetti ad ignorarmi smettila non
è vero sono ancora qui non non vedi non
riesci a vedere che cosa sta succedendo
non sei te stessa felice hai provato ad
uccidermi l'ha fatto due volte nota io
no menti non toccarmi lasciami sola va
beh almeno non tenta di uccidermi almeno
quello viola lasciare tranquillamente da
sola
felice felice io ti ho lasciato la sala
come chiesto porco demonio mandiamo via
andiamo via andavo via via in queste
scema per un attimo bisogno stava per
uccidermi sono misto stato per niente
allora andiamo alla chiave libeccio
libeccio vai vai let's go è l'ultima di
l'ultimo tipo di chiave in teoria o che
bello c'è anche bioshock
l'ho dentro il più interessante un
martello posso sfondare il muro
finalmente c'è un muro che possa
sfondare non so se ho tagliato dalla
parte dei living ve lo spiego io c'ho un
muro che si può sfondare finalmente
posso farlo vai la madonna che salve
amarico mi sa che esco di casa può
essere hai visto lo sapevo che usciva di
casa va sbloccata la porta ok
così è molto più easy una sega andiamo
nel quasi un'altra libeccio chi per caso
no ma ma come non lo sapevo come che
pirla ma quello ho sempre potuto
sbloccarla e non l'ho mai fatto che
pirla
no veramente dai che scemo fine eravamo
da questa parte per tutto il tempo lo
siamo stati che scivolo sapevo allora lì
sotto ci dovrebbe essere il muro sfonda
bile ecco mi pare fosse questa non
vorrei di una cagata
eccoci qua allora qua c'è un muro che
può essere sfondato con un attrezzo
let's go migliore è il martello di thor
ci sono parrucche ho trovato un solvente
grande wow adesso si che ci siamo
cosa me ne faccio ma posso raggiungere
l'altra finestra per uscire esci vai
esci chissenefrega vai
ok ci ho messo sei anni ma va bene
libeccio chi jugan red book c'è un libro
adesso tre libri sì però il problema
come come facili da torna indietro modo
rifare tutto cosa c'è un'altra volta qua
salve un'altra orribile scultura ma sei
tu che non capisci l'arte zip allora qua
c'è una un'altra porta chiusa libeccio
io che è l'ultima porta ad aprile consta
chiave e non ha idea di che cosa ci
possa essere potente o bello e una
libreria mancano libri ce l'ho io
celo celo celo filati allora io c'ho
quello rosso che non so se va inserito
qua devo inserirli proprio probabilmente
nel modo giusto
ora io qua c'è inserirei un giallo
perché ce ne sono troppo pochi e giusto
perfetto
a furia di provare cose a caso sia
aperto un quadro tra l'altro small chi
finalmente una piccola chiave che so
sicuramente doveva utilizzata non è vero
non ne ho la piu pallida scirocco manca
pur la scirocco chi va bene ora small
chi non so dove la vado ad usare però
avuto sicuramente molo troviamo allora
se mi ricordo bene non era co
assolutamente nella vita acqua di fianco
c'era un quadro dove posso sicuramente
usare solventi poveri sono molte donne
ne facesse solvente
ed è questo let's go e dentro ciò dei
numeri lawyer di bianco e 7 di numeri mi
chiedo se ce ne siano libri di quanti
riesci a vederne essendo no entrata non
lo è è vero forse c'è qualcosa porco
demonio porco che kakà non potete farmi
il pisticci bene tanto si era aperta la
porta in tutto questo ottimo e i ragazzi
con quello che citazioni sono divieti ci
diamo nel prossimo mettete laica and
everything che cosa stia gioco è proprio
bello quindi spero che le voci dei
ragazzi non mi piace anche per iniziare
dove si chiede e noi ci crediamo
[Musica]